[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry on
Francis Foster I'm Constance and Kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
and trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we asked the experts our
fantastic guest this week is Toby Young
who is a classical liberal journalist
Toby Young welcome to chicken antics
[Music]
I introduced you as journalists how did
you first get into journalists tell us a
little bit yeah well I um I first
started writing for newspapers of
magazines when I was a student I was
commended in the category of young
journalists of the year in God 1985 and
and when I left University I became a
news trainee at the times and that was
my first kind of proper job in
journalism I actually lost that job
after six months and the reason for that
was because every morning and I would
come in and try and log on to the
in-house computer system as Charlie
Wilson then the editor-in-chief of the
dimes how much access you had to the
kind of in-house computer system
depended on your status in the office
highrock him because I was a news
trainee I was at the bottom of the
pecking order and really had access to
nothing so I would try and log in as the
editor in order to get access to
everything I will try and guess his
password for kind of five or ten minutes
every morning and after about you know
five and a half months I hit on the
right one which was top man and the
first I had this very kind of
supercilious boss who had this kind of
very languid air long hair lots of
girlfriends drove an open-top mg yeah
and and and so the first thing I did
when I was in inside the editors kind of
I think it was called a queue when you
sent someone a message their name came
underneath so I immediately sent a
message to this this that might my
Overlord saying move your [ __ ] car
it's in my space the editor and he kind
of left up out of his chair so you've
been kind of hit with a cattle prod of
ran into the car and moved his mg to
another spot and I thought right I can
have some fun here and I read havoc for
about a week I found this memo detailing
all the salaries of the most senior
employees at the times and circulated
that kind of to the entire office and
then immediately people started queuing
up outside the editors door to kind of
demand more money because so that we're
getting more than them and anyway and
and then after after about a week of
this
the kind of IT please track down the
kind of miscreant it was kind of causing
trouble and I was I was told to meet the
managing editor for her kind of dressing
down and I went to the Managing Editors
office expecting you know a slap on the
wrist but to be secretly kind of admired
for having you know crucial skills for a
modern journalist and I was met by a
security guard with a kind of
see-through plastic bag containing the
contents of my office drawer and
escorted off the premises so that was
the end of my career as a new trainee at
the Times
I then went to Harvard for a year and
thought I've become an academic and
embarked on a PhD at Cambridge bend out
of that after two years started a
magazine called the modern revue with
Julie Burchill and Cosmo Landsman who
were then my next-door neighbors in
Islington the modern review was kind of
a magazine in which intellectuals and
academics wrote kind of long scholarly
pieces about things like Madonna and
Arnold Schwarzenegger
although culture for highbrows Judy but
used to described it as Smash Hits
edited by fr leavis which I guess makes
me fr leavis which is kind of
complementary and we kept that going for
four years and produced it out of my
kind of bed sit in Shepherds Bush and I
thought you know it was Jann Wenner kind
of their kind of dawn of the Rolling
Stone kind of Empire and I was gonna be
this kind of you know billionaire in
years to come with private jets because
this magazine was gonna be kind of so
incredibly successful it folded in 1995
after Julie and I fell out she left
Cosmo and ran off with an associate
editor called Charlotte Raven and it
became a bit of a kind of news story at
the time anyway I shut down the magazine
and at that point was recruited by
Graydon Carter than the editor of Vanity
Fair to go work for Vanity Fair he
initially said you know come out for a
month you know let's get to know each
other it'll be fun
and a month turned into three months
three months turned into six months and
I was eventually I was I was at Vanity
Fair for almost three years and in New
York for five years and I thought again
you know I was gonna conquer New York I
was getting the mail Tina Brown you know
here was the land of opportunity turned
out it was for me the land of the
return phone call and I crashed and
burned spectacularly and returned to
London in 2000 with my kind of tail
between my legs
but wrote a book about my disastrous
attempts to take Manhattan called how to
lose friends and alienate people which
was published in 2001 turned into a
stage play in which I played myself in
the West End for eight weeks sometimes
two full houses sometimes notes and I
used to get the flop sweat you know when
it's like someone turns on the
waterworks because no one's laughing at
your gags yeah I'll call it sweaty back
syndrome it's ready back syndrome okay
so you don't know about it and that book
was it became a best-seller sold it
around the world it was eventually
turned into a film in which Simon Pegg
played me which was released in 2008
also called how to lose friends and
alienate people wrote a sequel called
the sin of no hand-clapping but started
writing a column at The Spectator in 98
and in writing a column ever since also
an associate editor at The Spectator got
it's kind of into doing more political
stuff around about 2008 2009 and have
been kind of fairly political since then
wouldn't quite describe myself as an
activist journalist but probably on the
cusp of being that and on the
conservative side of things yeah yeah so
that's kind of that's my journalistic
career in a nutshell and how did you get
involved in education because that's
also been a big part of your life yeah
well um it ran about 2008 I my wife and
I started to look at local secondary
schools so we've got four kids and we
had the children in very quick
succession at one point worked out that
my wife was pregnant over a five-year
period for more than 50% of the time
excellent
my wife is a lawyer he gave up
practicing law to become a full-time mum
and we had our first child which I
always says the worst of all possible
combinations because she contributes
nothing to the household income but can
always beat me in an argument so she's
gone back to work now so if she was to
hear me saying that she would kill me
you know it does contribute and anyway
so we had these four kids they were all
at this really good local primary school
in Shepherds Bush but we were nervous
about whether we're gonna go to
secondary school and there are some good
it's around here actually there are some
good Catholics and good CoV secondary
schools but you have to be you know a
church-going Catholic or Anglican or to
get into those schools there were some
other really good secular schools but
the catchment areas were tiny and
practically had to live within the
school gate to get into those schools
and we sat down and thought well what
are we going to do we can either move we
can get religion which Randhir is known
as on your knees to avoid the fees none
of those none of those options seemed we
could go private being a freelance
journalist yeah for kids that wasn't
really an option so we initially decided
to move and my wife got all these
details of houses in this village in
Suffolk called parem which is near a
really good comprehensive school called
Thomas Mills
and and the plan was to move to parem in
Suffolk 200 miles away and about a
hundred miles away and sent our kids to
this this good local comprehensive but I
thought you know why should we have to
kind of uproot ourselves and move
halfway across the country just to
secure a decent state education for our
children shouldn't that be you know
available more locally plus you know
parem happen to be where my
parents-in-law live that wasn't a big
factory it was as though I was having to
move back into the basement it wasn't
quite the basement but almost the bottom
of the garden yeah my parents in-law
just to secure you know a decent
education for I didn't really want to
leave London and you know I just felt
angry about the fact that I was having
to jump through all these hoops to
secure
which should be everyone's by right if
you were a taxpayer and so forth anyway
so I thought maybe there's another
option which is to start our own school
and that's fascinating in itself because
most people's reactions now to that
situation would be to write a massive
Facebook post about yeah the educational
system is broken and everything yeah but
you actually did this horrendous thing
of trying to do something about it well
yeah I think I think it was some I agree
it's a slightly unusual reaction I think
one of the things that gave me the
confidence to think that was possible is
that my father was involved in education
he came up with the original idea for
the Open University which is now the
largest higher education institution in
Europe with you know something like a
quarter of a million students on roll at
any one time and so I you know I thought
well if he can start a university the
least I can do is start you know a small
secondary school plus at that time
Michael Gove was the shadow education
secretary and was talking about making
it possible for parents to set up free
schools which have been set up in
America as charter schools and in Sweden
in another European countries so look at
that point too as though the Tories were
get a kind of ROM poem in 2010 so it
seemed you know it didn't seem
completely beyond the realm of
possibility so I wrote this piece not a
Facebook post it was a piece for The
Observer in 2009 saying I wanted to
start what I called a comprehensive
grammar school so a school which
combined the best of both the grammar
and the comprehensive predictions so
mixed ability intake inclusive but
uniforms houses Latin grammar Hogwarts
meets Grange Hill and and and and I
published it and I put an email address
at the bottom saying anyone want to help
me you know email me and I got about 150
people emailing me saying they'd love to
help mainly local parents worried about
the same things as my wife and me and I
invited them all to a meeting in my
sitting room not much bigger than this
room here and about 50 people crowded
into the room this was in sort of I
guess September October 2009 and out of
that group in
emerged a group of about 12 people
almost all of whom were complete
strangers to me until that meeting and
they became the steering committee of
the West London free school and you know
we embarked on this kind of mammoth
undertaking and it was at times kind of
horrendously difficult
I remember when morale was at a
particularly low ebb I mean we got
nothing but the hand from Ed Balls
whenever we tried to it was then the
sector of state of dcsf known as the
department for chairs and soft
furnishings anyway but he was the
education secretary and was totally
uninterested in a kind of parent
promoted Academy which was how we build
it at the time and I remember inviting
this guy who led a parent group who'd
successfully established a Jewish
comprehensive the Jewish community
Secondary School in Barnet which was due
to open in September 2010 so he'd have
actually done what we were trying to do
it was a pair of promoted voluntary
aided school it was about to open you
know huge new buildings and it was a
huge success story and so I invited him
to come and address my little group my
little merry band try and raise morale
when I was at an all-time low and the
first thing he said was it took my group
ten years that's ten years of your life
you'll never get back as I said yes but
you know had you realized at the
beginning of that ten years that after
ten years you'd have this kind of
fantastic school embodying your vision
presumably wouldn't have done anything
any differently would you and he was
like are you kidding my wife's almost
left me on Pratley bankrupt my kids too
old to go to the bloody school I never
would have done it take ten years we
managed to recover from that kind of low
point and in 2011 in 2011 two years
later we became the first group to sign
a funding agreement with Michael Gove
when he became the secretary state for
education so the first free school to
get the green light and we were one of
the first 24 to open in 2011 Boris
Johnson opened the school this is when
he was still on speaking terms if
Michael goes you made a kind of friendly
gag he said give me a new word
which we keep thinking he could and we
and we we've been told a lot of things
by critics of the free schools policy
we've been told that teachers wouldn't
want to work at a kind of parent run
school because it would be an insult to
their professionalism actually we had
you know over a hundred applicants for
the head teacher position which is
believe me unheard of we were told the
parents wouldn't want to send their
children to the school the analogy was
you know if your kid burst his or her
appendix you wouldn't send him or her to
a hospital run by patients so why on
earth would a parent entrust their
precious child to a school run by
parents that wasn't really around their
parents it's run by professional
teachers but nonetheless you know we
would massively oversubscribe one of the
you know ten most oversubscribed mixed
ability state schools in england you
know everything people said would go
wrong didn't go wrong all the reasons
people said it wouldn't work turned out
to be kind of just false and we got our
first GCSE results our first set of GCSE
results in 2016 and they put us in the
top 10% mixed ability comprehensives in
england we've got our first kids
graduating from the sixth form this year
83% of them have had university offers
63% for Russell Group universities and
40% of the kids at the school are from
disadvantaged backgrounds that was
another thing people said they said that
the only the only parents who'd be
interested in sending their children's
for the critics to a school where Latin
was mandatory for the first three years
which it is would be kind of local
middle-class parents who couldn't afford
or who wanted to save the money on
private school fees and actually it's
got a an incredibly kind of mixed group
of kids at the school I mean you know
it's about a third black Asian minority
ethnic about 40 percent from
disadvantaged backgrounds it's you know
almost perfectly representative of the
local area it's just nonsense that you
know only white middle class people are
interested in securing a kind of
academically rigorous education for
their children it's just
dodging nonsense anyway it's been it's
been a huge success and subsequently
the group that emerged from that meeting
in my sitting room in 2009 went on to
create three more schools three primary
is also local also doing very well and
we've just been approved to open a
second second group in Cambridge in 2022
so that's been you know I've been I
thought that you know enjoying some
success as a as a journalist would be
kind of enriching and give my life
meaning and you know it was certainly
kind of great appear as myself and a
one-man show in the West End and I'd
co-produced a Hollywood movie based on
the book the book was a best-seller but
nothing was as enriching or as
meaningful as setting up these schools
and just getting involved with a group
of almost complete strangers I'm kind of
working collaboratively on this kind of
project that we really thought would
benefit the local community and I think
it has I mean originally I did it you
know for selfish reasons because I
wanted a good school to send my kids to
and three of my kids are now at the
school two are and one's about starting
September and the fourth will go next
year but it's become a kind of you know
mission since then I've become a kind of
passionate advocate for the free schools
program and you know don't believe what
the critics tell you about it last year
kids made more progress at free schools
according to the new progress eight
measure than they did at any other type
of school they're massively
oversubscribed
they're more likely secondary schools
more likely to admit disadvantaged
children than other schools many much
more likely to get outstanding Ofsted
results I mean the program has been
probably the most successful education
policy of the post-war period I think
and do you agree of academies because
there's a lot of teachers in particular
item particularly agree with the Academy
process I don't believe that corporate
businesses should have any place in
education would you ascribe to that or
do you think that a carry turning
schools into independent businesses is a
positive thing I think people I think
people often misunderstand what
academies are I mean free schools are a
sub
of Academies so free schools are legally
academies academies are often described
as kind of businesses but you can't set
up an academy unless you are a charity
so every academy every multi-academy
trust in England is a charity some of
them make a surplus but not many do and
I think you know keeping corporates out
of education is difficult I mean it's
not just that hasn't that doesn't date
back to when academies were first
introduced it long predates that you
know the people who supply the toilet
paper to the school of people who supply
the school dinners if they're externally
provided the utility providers these are
all corporations and it would be very
difficult to run a successful public
education service any more than it would
be to run a public health service
without the involvement of you know the
private sector so I don't think that in
itself is an evil the question is how
well do these schools do and is the
academies ation process beneficial or
harmful and I think that's an
interesting debate and I've just
actually written an essay about that for
a forthcoming book be encouraged by the
Institute of Economic Affairs which I
think was recently stung in a Guardian
this morning or yesterday ridiculous but
and I think it's a mixed picture but I
don't think that that schools run by
local authorities fared any better it
may be the academies ation isn't a magic
bullet and for that reason we should
pause before insisting that every school
becomes an academy but I think the
program itself has room for improvement
it's perfectible in a way that local
authority run schools seem kind of less
I mean one of the things that I've
always noticed when the difference
between Academy Schools and locally run
schools is a different and difference in
budgets where it appears that Academy
schools do get much more funding and
local authority schools get less and
then you have Ofsted coming going oh you
know this isn't working this isn't
working it's like well we had off a
million quid cut from our budget what do
you expect us to do yeah I think
that again is a myth put out by the
critics of the kind of whole panoply of
education reforms that date back to
Andrew Davis and Tony Blair but which
were kind of turbocharged by Michael
Gove in 2010 and have been continued
since academies and local authority
schools get the same money their per
pupil funding doesn't vary according to
whether they're an academy or a local
authority school in some cases local
authorities the money is channeled via
local authorities and they top slice it
and in most cases the local authority
top slice is larger than the top slice
say that a multi-academy trust will take
before then passing the money on to
schools and that that in in that it
where that happens then of course the
schools get less money but they can
either they supposedly get access to
services provided by the local authority
in return so it swings and roundabouts
but you know the Westland and free
school for instance the secondary school
that I co-founded we actually we
actually saw a bigger cut in our per
pupil real terms funding it was a cut of
2% if you compare 17 18 to 1819 compared
to some of the local authority schools
which actually saw an increase in that
funding so you know it's certainly not
true in Hammersmith and Fulham
[Music]
well listen we went to the next stage of
your career because this success with
the West London preschool and education
meant that you were then invited to
advise the government as part of a panel
or a board I think it was cool
yeah so I was invited well I applied to
be on this new higher education
regulator called the office for students
last year and I had to go through a
formal application process so I had to
submit a letter I had to provide
referees I was then interviewed by Sir
Michael barber the new chair of this
regulator as well as the vice chair and
an independent civil servant observer I
mean one of the criticisms made about
the process by which I was appointed was
that it wasn't above board but actually
I went through the same process as all
the other appointees but one of the
differences was that some of the student
applicants to the board had their social
media vetted whereas my social media
history wasn't vetted but then the
social media history of all the other
appointees saved for the student
applicants wasn't vetted either so I
wasn't treated any differently to all
the sort of 13 or so other people
appointed to this board and went through
exactly the same appointments process so
you were appointed as part of it 13 -
actually they're actually 15 so it was a
I was one of 15 non-executive directors
appointed to this new higher education
regulator and the Department of
Education announced the list of all the
appointees on at around midnight on the
1st of January of this year and within
about and the Guardian intern they ran a
story at one minute past midnight saying
something like Toby Young appointed to
help lead new universities regular
which was misleading because I wasn't
going to be helping to lead in any sort
of meaningful sense this regulator I was
one of 15 board members you know there
were executives a chief executive a
deputy chief and so forth who would be
leading it and there was a chair of this
board who would be leading it but I was
one of you know just 15 trustees anyway
that triggered a lot of people on
Twitter who immediately kind of started
objecting I started trending shortly
after midnight and people then stopped
same day on the same day yeah well with
it within within minutes within a minute
of this Guardian story going live yeah
and can I just ask what was your
emotions when you saw that it was
trending because sometimes when things
happen and I go on social media and I
see that I've been tagged in a post like
there's a little bit of drip that enters
my soul where I think what this is did
you have that or were you intrigued or
no I you know I suppose some like you I
sort of kind of think why is this
happening and sort of you have a kind of
you have a sort of slightly kind of a
slight feeling of thread in the pit of
your stomach and then and then I
realized it was people reacting to this
Guardian story and for the most part
coming up with kind of flimsy objections
as to why I shouldn't sit on this board
I mean the the most common objection was
that I didn't have a background in
higher education which was an odd
objection to make for someone who was
being appointed to a regular a regulator
I mean you don't want a sector to be
marking its own homework or at least you
don't want its homework to be entirely
mocked by people who are from that
sector I mean you know when when when
someone who works for or who worked for
Rupert Murdoch was appointed to it so
the left throws up its arms in horror
and talks about the industry marking its
own homework and yet here I was someone
who wasn't involved in higher education
being appointed directly and they were
throwing up their arms in horror because
I wasn't you know a vice chancellor or a
university or a professor or some kind
35 for a worldwide audience would you
mind just explaining what I'm so is so
if so is the
you press regulator that was set up in
the wake of the Leveson inquiry and
which replaced the existing regulator
and it's been criticized mainly by
people who would like to muzzle the
tabloid press because it isn't
state-authorized it's not the state
authorized regulator that hacked off
wanted to see as a result of Leverson
it's an independent a wholly independent
regulator and it has some some people
sit on it who have kind of worked in the
industry and others haven't it's a
mixture of people as is the office for
students so it just seemed to me to be a
ridiculous objection to say I wasn't fit
to serve on this regulatory body because
I wasn't employed by the sector are
supposedly regulating any well that
wasn't the objection that got the most
purchase no that was the initial wave of
objections and then and then people
started crawling through my Twitter feed
everything I'd ever posted on Facebook
and going back through everything I
written for The Spectator and elsewhere
Fraser Nelson the editor for The
Spectator wrote a piece in my defense
when this thing kind of mushroomed in
which he pointed out that the top most
searched-for
articles in the spectators archives
dating back to 1828 were all articles by
me as my detractors were kind of working
hard to try and uncover things that they
could then kind of pull out of context
and stick on Twitter and say how can you
appoint this person to a kind of public
body a guy called Freddy de Bourgh wrote
a really good blog post called planet of
the cops in which he talked about what
he called offense archaeologists people
who kind of devote themselves like
literally hours days of their lives just
to trawling through all the things they
can find about a particular target so
they can then find things to be outraged
about or claim to be offended by I mean
it's a kind of weird kind of political
moment in which people kind of can spend
all this time
trying to find things which they then
claim a really upsetting and triggering
and offensive and undermining their
mental health and sort of destroying
their sense of well-being it's like well
if things I've said are actually going
to do that to you why have you spent the
last five days trawling through my
Twitter feed in order to try and find
things that are going to upset you if
you really think they're upsetting and
offensive and should be prohibited in
some way why are you trying to broadcast
them forage want to upset other people
and it's a kind of weird kind of twisted
loss of course they're not really upset
or offended they're just pretending to
be Captain Renault star yet when when
Captain Renault discovers gambling is
taking place at Rick's place in
Casablanca he's shocked shocked to
discover gambling is going on unless
that's the kind of shock we're talking
about it too kind of make-believe
confetti shock discrediting a particular
person so what happened with Canton
killer because the police it was
actually the police in that case yes no
one was offended by three million people
watched the video on YouTube no one
complained about it and then if someone
made a complaint and the police went
around showing the clip to people to see
if they were offended and of course
eventually they found somebody it was
and this seems to be the thing so what
do I do you think you were targeted in
this way one of the interesting just
just just a linger for a second on that
particular example that is an example of
someone who is deemed to have said
something inappropriate and offensive
being prosecuted which i think is
extremely sinister yeah but what what
what's interesting and different about
the Big Brother role played by these
offense archaeologists is it's kind of
they're not state actors they're just
ordinary people I mean they're hashtag
activists for the most part and they're
kind of it's a sort of crowd-sourced Big
Brother it's not Big Brother as
presented in 1984 it's not a big brother
with the imprimatur of the state trying
to shame people and and and denude them
of their livelihoods and kind of run
them out of town as it were on a rail
tar and feather them with the authority
of the state it's just ordinary people
hashtag
activists kind of assembling in order to
kind of recreate this kind of oppressive
Big Brother figure and for that reason I
think in some ways that bad as a source
of hope because if everyone stands up to
them then I think their power would be
much reduced but unfortunately because
that's not happening corporations large
bureaucracies governing political
parties are just doing their bidding so
even though they're not state actors
that it's just a kind of crowd
assembling an outraged mob assembling on
Twitter and on social media
nonetheless they have they can Vic they
have they had this extraordinary power
because various state bodies various
organs and instruments of the state
start acting or start doing their
bidding but I think the count dunk Euler
cases is extremely sinister because
that's an example of the police trying
to almost second-guess what an outraged
mob is likely to ask them to do should
it spring up even though in this case as
you say it hadn't actually sprung up so
coming back to you then you had these
people trolling through your Twitter
post on Facebook post what did they find
they found yeah they found a number of
articles and tweets I'd written which in
their view made me unsuitable to serve
on this public regulator so for instance
a piece I'd written an essay I'd written
on leaving University in 1988 so 30
years ago was in which I talked about
how the English class system operated at
Oxford and made some sort of faintly
disparaging remarks of disparaging kind
of description rude descriptions of
socially awkward boys and that was taken
to be indicative of my contempt for
working-class boys who tried to make
good through education Paul Masson
pulled this out as evidence that I was a
totally unsuitable person to serve on
this regular and he said that the reason
that Tories had appointed me to this
regulatory body was in order to stop
working class children going to
university
was my role I mean literally I don't
know where he believes this or not but
this is what he actually said in a tweet
for those who don't know Paul Mason as a
former BBC and channel 4 journalist
turned kind of freelance corbin easter
activist and and he kind of think what
you know first of all you've totally
misinterpreted this piece secondly it
was written 30 years ago you know even
if I had said the things you're claiming
I said in that article what about all
the work I've done since you know at
Oxford I was involved in a widening
participation program to encourage
children from disadvantaged areas to
apply to the University and went and
talked to six forms you know around the
country to cry and persuade children who
hadn't considered Oxford to apply to
Oxford I've been at that stage a member
of the Fulbright the UK u.s. Fulbright
Commission and we have this program in
partnership with the Sutton trust
whereby we secure full scholarships for
English kids from disadvantaged
backgrounds to attend u.s. colleges I'd
set up you know four schools at the
primary schools we give priority to
children from disadvantaged backgrounds
when they apply at the secondary school
40% of the kids from disadvantaged
backgrounds I mean what's Paul Mason
ever done to help kids from
disadvantaged backgrounds get to
university I mean sweet [ __ ] all I
imagine
and I'd but here he was judging me on
the basis of an essay he'd misunderstood
written 30 years ago and saying that is
the reason Toby Young shouldn't be
appointed to this to this particular
regulatory body and that was kind of
typical of I think the way in which
outraged mobs on Twitter work they pull
out particular things you've written
them and I said some stupid things about
women's breasts you know after several
glasses of wine at sort of four o'clock
in the morning nine ten years ago and
those were pulled out as evidence that I
was a misogynist opposed to women going
to university and you know often these
these tweets were reproduced with the
hashtag me too as though tweeting about
boobs for
in the morning is identical morally
indistinguishable from you know Harvey
wine what Harvey Weinstein has been
accused of doing which you know I think
it's the it's the it's the it's the
feminist equivalent of playing the race
card you know don't expect people to
become outraged every time you use the
me to hash tag if you're going to use it
to describe you know locker room banter
and not kind of rape and sexual
harassment and unpleasant predatory
behavior in the workplace but you know
I've never been accused of sexual
harassment I've I've run several medium
sized organizations I've never been
accused of sexual discrimination never
been taken to a cribe unil nothing
I think anything like that but because I
you know I sent some unfortunate tweets
that made me a misogynist in the eyes of
my critics and therefore a totally
unsuitable person to be appointed to
this body what's it like emotionally
when you see slowly but surely this
picture being constructed of you of who
you are which actually bears very little
resemblance to the truth but then you
see more and more people just look at it
and go well he's obviously that person
yeah and I mean I find that soul destroy
because it just reminds me of you know
the play The Crucible where John Proctor
goes that's my name that's the only
thing that I have it is it is that that
is that is one of the worst things about
it this feeling that you know your name
is being dragged through the mud people
are saying these terrible things about
you and attributing these terrible
beliefs to you this is awful sense that
people who don't know you even even
people who know you a little bit might
see these things and believe they're
true and that is that's an awful feeling
so that probably the low point was
watching question time and massive the
UK's leading ending coming Affairs
flagship kind of first program in which
a panel of people discuss kind of
a number of kind of fuzzy kind of topics
of the day
so dawn Butler labor Shadow Minister for
women and equalities said on question
time that I was a eugenicist who talked
about weeding out disabled people and
when it was just I mean it was just
complete nonsense constructed out of
whole cloth and you know I've got a
disabled brother I'm a patron of the
care home he lives in and the thought
that he or any of his carers or any of
his friends you know in that community
might be watching question time and
thinking crumbs didn't know that about
Toby didn't know that about my brother
he wants to weed me out you know this is
a serious person saying this on on this
flagship current affairs program a
senior politician must be true you know
that was that was terrible and I think
what was one of the one of these
salutary things about that experience it
was also another moment with there was a
House of Commons to pay again the
Speaker of the House of Commons John
burka in his wisdom described just
decided to grant an emergency debate an
urgent question about my appointment to
this body and that and the kind of labor
objections were led by Dawn Butler again
and just everything that came out of her
mouth was wrong I mean it was often kind
of garbled stories from how to lose
friends and alienate people okay if you
write a kind of self-deprecating memoir
in which you tell all these terrible
embarrassing stories about yourself then
I suppose you know if you do then get
appointed to a public body it's
inevitable that someone is gonna trawl
through that book and triumph and the
way they present it it's as though they
threw their sleuthing you know through
their kind of powers as kind of forensic
investigators they've discovered these
kind of terrible terrible things about
time now I wrote them all about myself
and a self deprecating memoir but
Kingsley Amis the British author once
wrote that yeah be careful when you make
a self-deprecating remark about yourself
because some little [ __ ] is bound to dig
it up at some point in the future and
hurl it against you because you watch an
article about pornography
yeah and that was used against you as
well wasn't it in order to sooner
anything it was just it was that there
were moments during this kind of hole
for Rory which were comic and that was
one of them so I wrote a piece in 2001
for The Spectator disputing that the
liberalisation of the attitude of the
British Board of Film classification to
pornography whereby they were allowing
more things to get through wasn't going
to result in a kind of epidemic of
sexual violence and the literature
linking exposure to sexual imagery
including pornography to sexual violence
was you know the evidence was incredibly
threadbare most of the evidence is that
there wasn't any link at all I mean
Diana Fleischman who whose episode of
ours you've seen she wrote an article
and one of the points she makes and
though the increased use of pornography
reduces new sexual life exactly and you
can you can see that at a very crude
level if you compare societies in which
there's a very liberal attitude towards
pornography like Sweden Denmark Holland
two countries in which there's a very
sense aureus draconian attitude towards
pornography like Saudi Arabia the
incidence of sexual violence is much
much higher in those countries which
have a much more draconian adair I made
this point in this article and I like in
the in the course of making this
argument IIIi I described Philip Larkin
the British poet generally regarded as
you know probably the best British poet
of the post-war period was offered the
poet laureate ship turned it down came
up with the line all that remains of us
is love as well as the famous poem about
your parents [ __ ] you up anyway
he was once loitering outside of Soho
sex shop too embarrassed to go in and
the owner came out and said was it
bundage sir and I relayed this anecdote
which he told to Kingsley Amis in a
letter to Kingsley Amis and I described
him in the course of relaying this
anecdote as a fellow porn addict not
meaning that he was a porn addict or
that I'm a porn addict
it was a kind of self-deprecating remark
not intended to be taken at face value
but someone one of these offense
archaeologists kind of found this piece
and that the sub at the spectator had
put the headline atop of the piece
confessions of a porn addict so he
reproduced this piece on Twitter
literally minutes later it appeared in
the Evening Standard headline you know
new pressure mounts on Teresa may as
universities are confesses to being porn
addict quote-unquote and that was
reproduced in the times that I
experiment one of the one of the kind of
eye-opening things about this whole
experience was realizing the extent to
which the mainstream media and their
just takes its cue from social media
without doing any kind of checking
there's no that you'd expect higher
standards to be shown by journalists for
the Evening Standard and the times than
by you know an amateur offense
archaeologist on Twitter but no they
produce something embarrassing about you
and it's just immediately reproduced as
though ah you know they've discovered
that this guy's a porn addict that'll
embarrass the p.m. you know because the
prime minister effectively appointed me
to this this regulatory body anyway so
it's just kind of ridiculous but one
thing I was gonna say in response to
your point is what was it like to just
see people dragging your name through
the mud and this kind of horrible
feeling of powerlessness that you can't
do anything about it
yeah you can you can object but you're
not a great witness in your own defense
people and don't take that particularly
seriously you hope other people will
kind of leap to your defense and some
people did but not that many do in these
situations because people are frightened
of these Twitter mobs understandably and
for me I I did think at the time this
must be what it's like for you know
people not involved in the media people
who don't have any power or influence or
money to see their names produced in the
media that feeling of powerlessness must
be what it's like for ordinary people
when a story appears about them which is
completely wrong and they don't feel
they can kind of they have any redress
they can't leak and complaint it it so
and I didn't complain so I did complain
to the guardians on
that's man and that was a total waste of
time so all of this happens your name is
dragged through the mud you're
eventually forced to well you you you
forced or did you choose to apologize
and resign fight I I decided after nine
days of mounting pressure to resign and
apologize and you know it was becoming
an untenable situation a petition had
been got up with something like 225
thousand signatures on change.org
demanding I be sacked and there was a
mob of reporters outside my house
waiting to kind of ambush me you know
whenever I left or came home my 14 year
old daughter was kind of refusing to
leave the house my wife said that if
another person came up to her at the
school gate and said you know are you
okay she was gonna hit them you know and
very quickly well with your wife were
they commiserating with you as a family
or were they saying to her are you okay
coexisting with this evil misogynist you
Jan no I think they were saying are you
how are you coping
this kind of onslaught of of abuse of
your husband I don't and they were
saying how oh you all right as in you
know you're right living with this kind
of vile misogynist no I think I think
they were did but you know when people
work I mean I wasn't there I don't know
what what their attitude was when they
were saying it but generally when people
kind of express pity and concern it's
always kind of tinged with a kind of
little bit of Glee anyway the other
difficulty was that the the other
members of the board were at this point
threatening to resign if I didn't resign
and that was putting sir Michael
barbar in a very difficult position he
didn't want to have to kind of choose
between siding with me or siding with
these other members of the board and it
was kind of casting a kind of huge pall
over the launch of this new regulator
which I think has an important role to
play one of its one of its jobs is going
to be protecting free speech on British
campuses another is going to be trying
to stop kind of runaway salaries for
wildly ever paid Vice Chancellors try
and do something about the grade
inflation universities so it's got lots
of important things to do and you know I
believe in its mission and so I realized
I wasn't helping it any by kind of
clinging on and this story kind of
continuing to dominate the news so I
resigned and I'd been advised by by some
people that if you resign and apologize
then you know don't expect don't expect
the outraged mob to then disperse and go
oh okay
he's apologized let's move on find
another victim it just emboldened them
even further I said if you resign and
apologise they'll just come after you
and demand you step down from all your
other jobs they'll come after prison
Elson at The Spectator they'll see it as
an admission a blanket admission of
guilt
everything you've accused me of I'm
guilty of I am this terrible person you
are right and that is actually more or
less exactly what happened so the moment
I step down from the office of students
and apologised their various various
leaders of teaching unions demanded that
I step down from the free schools
charity I was running demanded that I
stepped down from any involvement with
the schools I'd set up the Fulbright
Commission came under pressure somehow
got a kind of page up on Facebook
claiming to be a paid representing other
Fulbright Scholars wanting my scalp so I
had to step down from the Fulbright
Commission I was an honorary fellow of
buckin University and I got an email
from
University telling me that actually I'm
misunderstood and my honorary fellowship
which was granted in something like 2011
was only for three years so it had
expired in 2014 so I could no longer
call myself and I like hang on a second
I spoke at this festival of education at
[ __ ] University last year and you
build me in the program as an honorary
fellow so this is news to me anyway so
that was their kind of sneaky so they
went away sneaky way of stripping me
about the honor and eventually I did
have to stand down from the free schools
charity I was running and I had to stand
down from the Board of Trustees of the
charity that the four schools I'd helped
set up sat within so in total I was I
lost four no five positions as a result
of this kind of outrage let me ask you
this one final thing sorry Francis on
this from my side I know it might seem
like an insensitive question from
someone like me who hasn't been through
but I always wonder when I see somebody
being smeared in this way the the
previous comments being misused by
people in many cases who are no better
than the person that they're talking
about if you go through their Twitter
feed you have mine exactly the same
thing I mean I can see why you resigned
in the sense that it was sabotaging the
work of the board to which you've been
appointed and it was going to be but in
terms of your apology why does no one
ever stand up to these people and say
you bunch of sanctimonious hypocritical
[ __ ]
why don't you go and look at your own
behavior we're all flawed we're all
human none of us never make mistakes
we're all like this so I'm not gonna
apologize for being human I'm doing my
best here's the work that I've been
doing I'm not going to apologize why
does nobody ever do that I think I saw
you do that I think sometimes people do
do that and yeah and that can sometimes
be a better strategy than apologizing I
I felt I felt the need to apologize
partly because you know I did feel
contrite about some of the things I'd
said on Twitter
you know there were there were there
were some things that when they were
reproduced one which we produced on the
front page of The Mail on Sunday some
stupid gag I'd made about starving
children in Africa during a kind of
red-nosed a English telethon broadcast
and you know when when when that when
that tweet was reproduced on a front
page of The Mail on Sunday yeah my first
thought was thank God my dad's not still
alive you know because this is so
shaming and yes there were certain
things I had said that I did regret
saying and so I thought I ought to
apologize for saying them but I also
hoped that if I if I if I step down and
apologized I naively thought that would
draw a line under and I could continue
my work with the schools I've set up but
the work I was doing helping other
people set up free schools that turned
out to be you know a mistake but that
was that was my reasoning at the time
the reason I asked is like I understand
that you were contrite about some of the
things that it said but you know the two
of us are comedians the number of times
we've gone on stage and we tried to make
a joke about something and it just
hasn't worked or it's offended straight
for yourself like you were telling me
about last night made don't don't do
this the number of times that you tried
to do something doesn't quite work or
you say something that's out of place or
whatever it's a normal part of human
existence to make mistakes why does your
having said something that you regret
means that you now have to be treated as
this pariah that's something I don't
understand well I think I think that I
mean I agree with that I think it's I
think that you know people should be
judged in the realm right you should
judge people according to the totality
of their behavior and not judge them
according to the worst things they've
done
it's like defining people by their worst
moments taking taking taking a lapse of
judgment in which they've you know made
a gag which didn't work and which could
be construed as
offensive to some people taking that as
the defining moment in someone's life
which then completely eclipses
everything else they've done so you
could be someone who worked with kind of
handicapped children your entire life
you could have a handicapped younger
brother whom you've supported selflessly
your entire life but if you make one
joke about handicapped children suddenly
you are a kind of a terrible person and
all the work you've done everything else
you've done is completely disregarded
one of the one of the points I made in
my piece about all this for Colette that
was published last week is that we've
reached a this kind of strange point in
our society where by virtue signaling is
considered more important Trump's
actually being virtuous so not breaching
speech codes which restrict what you can
say about disadvantaged groups is
actually considered more important than
helping disadvantaged groups so the fact
that I've you know done all this work to
help disadvantaged kids dating back you
know 30 35 years it's less important
when it comes to judging my character
and whether I'm a fit and proper person
to serve our public regulator then one
thing I said about disadvantaged kids in
a piece in The Spectator 20 years ago do
you think that this urge and this desire
and this lust of publicly shamed people
comes is inherent in our character and
if you look at the medieval times things
like the stalks I think where do you
think this comes from why do you think
some people get so much of a vicarious
pleasure and and just I don't even
gratitude I think is a word to see
someone publicly shamed loser career
when you actually know deep down then
you were making a serious impact on
someone's mental health and not only on
their mental health but the mental
health of the people around them I think
I think I think he and I've thought
about this
and I think it's I think it must have
something to do with the disgust
instinct it's the same root as racism so
I think a particular group in order to
solidify its sense of cohesiveness in
order to create a sense of belonging and
community and common purpose sometimes
vilifies certain individuals who are in
its view members of an alt group and
that dates back to I think what they're
appealing to is the kind of human
disgust instinct this sense if
something's bad for you if it's going to
contaminate you in some way then you
automatically kind of push it out and
you want to destroy it and you also
think anyone else who comes into contact
with it it's going to be similarly
contaminated and they have to be kind of
cast out as well I think it's to do with
that I think it's Dan Magette in groups
have always tried to dehumanize and
other out groups and in some cases
individuals who are emblematic of those
out groups just in order to create a
sense of identity and community within
the in-group and that's probably more
likely to happen when societies are in a
state of flux and when there's a lot of
uncertainty and when the identity when
the values of the in-group becoming kind
of vaguer and more amorphous and let's
define a quick way of affirming a sense
of identity and common purpose is to
find some individual who they can all
collectively express their disgust for
and their contempt for and you know some
people say to me do you think if people
realized what it was like what it's like
for people who find themselves being
targeted by these twitch fault mobs do
you think if people realize that there
is a human being kind of twisting on the
end of that pitchfork and that they are
suffering and their families are
suffering and there's been no due
process effectively lynching someone do
you think if they realized you know if
you made them poor
and you actually explained the various
shortcomings of the process which has
led to this point and the impact it's
having on the individual that they would
reconsider I think they would and I
think it's a kind of bloodlust yeah and
if they find out that you're suffering
yeah and you know that's just kind of
that just kind of makes them yeah that
the even more crazy and frenzied in
their desire to destroy you like a pack
of wolves and you think the fact that
you're a white middle-class male who
went to Oxford do you hint that made you
even more fair game yes I mean I think I
think left-wing politics has taken an
identity in turn I mean if identity
politics isn't new it's been around you
know since at least the 1960s but it's
generally been associated with the hard
regressive left and that has been kept
at bay with in most left-wing movements
left-wing political parties I think
since the triumph of brexit and Trump
the regressive lurked identitarian 's
have seen their influence within the
left increased dramatically partly
because it's as though their claims that
capitalism inexorably leads to fascism
and the periods of economic uncertainty
produce kind of dangerous right-wing
populist movements it looks as though
their analysis has some purchase I mean
I think they're wrong about that and
that is what's going on but you can see
if you're a kind of soft leftist you
suddenly see these things happening it
looks as though these prophets to the
left of you are actually onto something
and also I think they feel that with the
apparent political surge resurgence of
of right-wing populist leaders and
causes across Europe and across the West
that they need to kind of stick together
so they no longer need it's no longer
appropriate to keep the hard regressive
left at bay they have to make common
cause at least until these kind of
demons have been defeated so I think the
various reasons identitarian ism is on
the march and you see it in universities
you see it amongst public intellectuals
you see it in public bureaucracies in
large corporations they all seem to be
suddenly dancing to the identitarian
tune and if
you are a kind of apex predator any
identitarian food chain you know if
you're a white heteronormative male from
a privileged background worse if you're
a Tory a brexit supporting Tory with all
those characteristics then they just
assume that you must have all these kind
of terrible toxic beliefs you must be a
misogynist you must be a racist you must
be a homophobe because that's how you
justify your privilege it doesn't occur
to them you know that there could be a
kind of perfectly reasonable
intellectual case for free market
capitalism they just assume that anyone
defending capitalism if they're a white
heteronormative male it must be because
they're trying to defend their privilege
and that they therefore subscribe to
these kind of toxic beliefs which
exclude other people from power and
preserve the structural inequality which
is kind of killing people who are
minorities and so forth and people of
color and women and so on and so forth
so I think they were very willing to
believe that because I had because i
taked all these kind of demographic
boxes that i held all these toxic
beliefs so then they set out to find
evidence that i did indeed hold these
beliefs and you know didn't take them
long to find it and i think as well one
thing reading your article going to
research about you okay so what I've
noticed as well as it does seem which I
find really interesting actually because
my mother's left in Latin American and
I've got a whole side of my family who
were not white and all the rest of it
and I just this is entirely for my dad's
side from County Leitrim but there we go
but one thing I've noticed with people
is they'll go alright yeah but he's just
a white male therefore you know it
doesn't matter because he's not
oppressed and therefore anything that I
am doing to him no matter how
unreasonable is just a way of mere
addressing the balance mm-hmm and that's
how they justify their arguments would
you agree with that I think I think that
is that is in some cases how they
justify their arguments yes but it's
it's I think it's a way of Licensing
them
to be unthinkingly cruel and dismissive
and contemptuous of people who they
think of as being members of out groups
they think you know for years people of
color minorities non cisgendered people
have been oppressed and therefore we're
perfectly entitled to mete out that
treatment to people who don't fall into
those categories but it's a kind of
isn't that kind of it's it's the same
kind of category error there's racism to
think that because white men were
slavers in the 18th century that they're
for every white male is in some measure
responsible for enslaving people because
Harvey Weinstein
in all likelihood we don't know for sure
the trial is continuing yeah raped
someone
therefore all white men are rapists I
mean it's it is exactly the equivalent
error as thinking that because a person
of color commits a crime that therefore
all people of color are criminals and
you would hope that rather than just
reproducing this category error and
applying and just and just kind of
reversing it as it were and applying it
to another group of people they would
say actually that's a category error and
it's wrong to judge people according to
the color of their skin or their gender
or their sexual orientation or whether
they're cysts or nonces but they seem to
have gone from you know saying but
that's wrong which I don't think anyone
you know would dispute whether a
classical liberal or a Marxist to saying
ah it's not wrong to judge people on the
basis of the color of their skin or
their sexual orientation
we've just been judging the wrong people
body we're just going to flip it so now
if you're a white heteronormative male
you're a bad person but if you're a
person of color and your mom cisgendered
and you're a woman then you're a good
person which is just it just seems
completely incomprehensible
I mean it's a very very good point you
make how much of the blame would you
ascribe to social media and Facebook in
particular the fact that you know that
people now who scream the loudest who
make accusations they seem to be the
most dominant voices what you I consider
myself on the left but I look at these
certain extreme members of the left and
I think you don't represent me in any
shape or form but somehow you were now
seemed to be the voice of the left in
inverted commas and is again with the
right you know you've seen Katie Hopkins
getting wheeled out and I've got lots of
friends who are conservatives and they
horrified by her and have rhetoric yeah
I think he I think it's I mean I think
social media undoubtedly has played a
part in coarsening political debate
lowering the standard of political
discourse making ad hominem attacks much
more prevalent and much more effective I
don't think that it's wholly responsible
and I think those those things have
always been there some of the kind of
you know those sorts of impulses and
even in different political periods
you've seen kind of you know I mean
there was a lot of fake knee they've
been for there's been fake news in u.s.
presidential elections dating back to
you know the dawn of the Republic but it
does seem to have it does seem to have
escalated and got a lot worse since the
sort of social media moment and it'll be
interesting to see if we can do anything
about that I mean I think this is an
interesting example isn't it I mean it's
some instead of trying to carve out a
voice for yourselves within the
mainstream media though you may be doing
that as well you've effectively created
a different platform for yourself in
part because you don't think anymore you
don't mean you don't have the confidence
that ideas will be debated and taken
seriously and we can have a proper
grown-up mature well-informed
conversation on mainstream media ready
more mainstream media's effectively been
corrupted by social media and it's kind
of sensationalist and as clickbait t now
a social media so to create
space to have a much more grown-up
well-informed conversation in which you
can seriously consider different ideas
and get to the bottom of things you have
to do it outside the mainstream media
and create a space for yourself to do it
I think what one source of hope is in
the same way that you know the Internet
has had a net negative impact on the
level of political debate here America
elsewhere so it's also created space for
programs like this and for people like
Dave Rubin and Jordan Peterson and you
know to actually have proper grown-up
quite long conversations about what what
really matters and even and one of the
reasons I think that you know platforms
like this are important and gaining
traction is because people are fed up
with that kind of petty name-calling
shaming just that kind of you know the
the dominance of that kind of woke
mindset that kind of permeates social
media and now the mainstream media it's
fascinating that you'd say that Toby
because if you look at our YouTube
channel and the number one type of
comment that we get is about my personal
appearance is actually to keep those
coming but the second most common common
is BBC channel for take now this is how
you do an interview I which TV was like
this I wish more people did this people
are absolutely crying out for people to
be having serious genuine conversations
for hearing all sides for hearing an
open conversation you know we get a lot
of hate by the way for having sent to
write figures on we invite we've invited
Owen John's on we've invited people
James O'Brien people from the left
people from the car social justice that
a car that we'd love to have on but the
problem that I think we have now is the
far left is becoming culturally
hegemonic in our debate in our
conversation and so those people don't
need to come on a renegade YouTube show
because they can go on the mainstream
media every day of the week and talk
there and not be interrupted every three
seconds and not be character
assassinated and I think that's that's
where what we're doing here is is
getting the purchase that it's getting
because there is no way to have genuine
conversation now on television it just
doesn't happen it's all Kathy Newman
esque
and all you see is someone being
interrupted every three seconds and you
can't have a conversation like that you
know and one of the things we find as
well as when we talk to somebody for a
long time if their flaws in their
thinking if their flaws in their logic
we don't need to batter them into
submission for that to be shown up we
just need to let them talk and ask
probing questions as we have done and
those flaws will expose themselves
without anybody being insulted or
offended or anything like that so we're
very grateful for you coming on and I
think I think that's where the future
isn't I hope that's where it is but let
me let me ask you one final question or
two final questions you told us you're a
classical liberal for for British
audience you maybe let people who don't
watch dave rubin as we do what is a
classical liberal and what is your
elevator pitch to people who may not yet
be classical liberals to join that cause
okay I think a classical liberal is
someone who believes in natural rights
they believe that insofar as the state
enjoys certain powers it's because those
powers have been granted to the state by
the people and and they can be taken
back so the kind of earth text for
classical liberals is probably John
Locke's Second Treatise of government in
which he describes the state of nature
and how rights get transferred from
people in the state of nature to the
state but we also believe in limited
government low taxation freedom of
speech religious tolerance we also
believe in progress that actually things
are getting better and across the world
and in particular since the creation of
free-market capitalism
things have been on a really steep
upward improvement curve not just in the
West but in
- are you really are nothing okay listen
the last question we always like to ask
our guests is what do you think is the
one thing that none of us are talking
about that we really should be talking
about well one thing that slightly
troubled me is the way in which people
on the center-right and the right have
been using the shaming tactics of people
on the left to go after people on the
left so for instance James Gunn the
director of guardians of the galaxy
volumes 1 and 2 and who was also
directing volume 3 was recently fired by
Disney because various inappropriate
things he had said on Twitter I mean
quite a few things and you know even if
I say so myself a lot worse the things I
had said but nonetheless you know things
he'd said for the most part quite late
at night on Twitter and she was trying
to kind of play the role of an edge Lord
and kind of intelliscore colored jokes I
mean very risky and off-color in his
case but but but but those tweets were
identified by people on the right and
they thought he was fair game because he
has opposed Trump and he has demanded
that people like various directors who
he thinks her sexually harassed women
should be fired so he sort of joined
outrage mobs before he's not quite a
Witchfinder general but he certainly
kind of you know he's complicit so they
thought fair game but I and it seems to
me it seems to be just becoming
generally accepted on kind of my side of
the divide that you know it's okay to
deploy those tactics against people on
the left and the rationale is if we
apply those tactics to them then they're
going to stop applying them to us in due
course because they're going to realize
that you know if we play that game
we'll lose as much as we gain I think
that that
that that that should we should pause
and think very carefully before
embracing those tactics and of course I
would say that because I've actually
been through it and I realized how
unpleasant and unfair being judged in
that way is but I also think you know
that the correct response to this
phenomenon is not to just is to say yeah
people on the left equally guilty and
here's why but to say actually people
shouldn't be judged according to lapses
of judgment stupid things they've said
in the middle of the night after several
glasses of wine you should take them in
the round and see what they're like as
human beings over the course of their
lives and not just try and skewer them
according to their worst possible
moments and and if we do engage in the
same tactics I think we surrender any
principle we have over trying to
defenestrate people on that basis and I
also think that we don't need to engage
in those tactics because the left if
left of the red devices will turn those
tactics on themselves I mean you see it
over and over again Mary beard for
instance who is that kind of
dyed-in-the-wool lefty has been several
times kind of targeted by twitch fault
mobs for kind of being insufficiently
woke in various comments she made about
the Oxfam scandal for instance you know
the left is constantly going after its
own you know there's the old phrase the
right looks for allies the left looks
for traitors I mean not always true but
broadly true so we don't have to engage
in those tactics ourselves in order to
eventually make sure that this kind of
public shaming stops because they will
turn those tactics on themselves and in
due course realize that there is no way
to behave Toby that was amazing thank
you very very much um before we go is
there anything you'd like to promote
your Twitter or if you've got articles
or books or whatever might be I think
the thing I'd like
promote is qualit for viewers listeners
you haven't yet discovered quill net it
is this online Australian magazine
started by a former Australian grad
student called Claire Lehmann next time
you're in London we're waiting for you
and it was it was singled out in Barry
Weiss's piece about the intellectual
dark web in the New York Times magazine
a couple months ago as ground zero of
the intellectual dark web I mean it has
articles by academics intellectuals
journalists comedians comedians you've
written for them absolutely and you know
the the level of debate in in collect is
incredibly high the standard of argument
of evidence is incredibly high it's all
informed by kind of mainstream science
it's a scientifically literate
publication I mean it's an extraordinary
breath of fresh air it's like a kind of
beacon of light and the kind of Darkling
plain and I've recently become an
associate editor there and very proud to
be associated with it and I've written
some things for it to my piece about
being publicly shamed six months ago
appeared in court last week I could what
the public humiliation dive because well
things that happens when you're publicly
shamed just without seeming to help it
you just shed pounds I need to go that's
coming yeah Jim what's the point in that
it's not see absolute yeah that's where
it's at because they all look good in
uniform right well well done for plug
equal a but you are on Twitter at totemo
still at my stepmonster check out some
of Toby's articles he's a great writer
thank you very much for tuning in do
subscribe to our youtube channel and if
you already subscribe to our youtube
channel make sure you click that bell
next to the subscribe button to make
sure that you get notified every time we
put out a fantastic video like this
we'll be back next week thank you very
much for tuning in and we'll see you
next time bye